et has your exclusive look at the new  angry birds trailer it's a real roller  coaster it's what's the movie it's not a  real Custer yet  hey red how are you oh I'm horrible mr.  rear yes you could be a recurring issue  angle am i a passionate bird oh yes but  why does it matter that we're not the  same  Bobby the anger might be contagious he  started it bringing I am a pig what's a  big show them how we do it how you doing  is that what I think it is scuze me  those are fragile right not yours you  all make it I will get feel unwelcome  and you're not asking basic questions  well this just got awkward doesn't  anyone see what's going on here the  whole world is in danger and it's up to  us to stop oh my god  if anyone knows what these pigs are up  to it's mighty eagle it's my Eagles like  wisdom get out of there don't spit in  his mouth don't swallow it  it's him  Oh  horrible turn of events horrible  you